so 20 years ago people were trying to
celebrate the Millennium a year early
and that's another video phenom
that's enough by one issue right yeah
that was not the millennium book so
there have been for about probably about
15 years beforehand people in the
computer science trade realized there
was a potential problem with the way
computer software is written and they
didn't know which bits of software this
could affect they didn't know where the
software's running whether it was
controlling critical infrastructure or
working out someone's pension results or
whatever it could be doing or just sort
of an arcade game down the street but
there was a potential that there's a bug
in this code some people might call it
feature depending on how you look at it
that could have been catastrophic I
remember people saying our cash machines
are gonna spew out loads of money and
planes are gonna fall out of the sky and
all this sort of stuff but it never
happened it was all the big ruse wasn't
it no
saw those a risk they then said well
okay this could be a potential danger
let's identify what it's going to hit
let's fix the problems before it's a
potential danger and so actually what
happened on January the first 2000 is
that there was a few minor issues I
think HSBC had problems with credit card
transactions over that period there
might have been some issues with some
wind sensors in airports and things but
there was nothing major that happened
and so most people think it was just a
sort of ruse and sort of a fuss over
nothing because people had gone and
fixed the problems at the heart of the
problem with the millennium bug comes
down to whether there's three things you
can look at it how did people represent
data what assumptions did they make
about things having represented data
that way and perhaps the other one that
was surprising was the longevity of
software so I think the classic want to
think about this is if I write down a
date I'm going to use day month year in
these examples so sorry
this is what I'm going to use so let's
suppose we have a person that's calling
Tom whose birthday is that how old is he
so fourth of November nineteen so I'm
saying 1919 is a hundred and maybe about
a month old okay right okay what about
someone that's called a Jones who was
born then how old are they ninth so yeah
maybe a little bit younger than him yeah
so this person is let's say around 100
years old and this person is about must
say about six weeks this is the root of
the problem there was a in the
millennium Burgas that we write down
years in an abbreviated form so rather
than writing down in this case 1919 and
in this case writing down 2019 we just
write down for 11 19 as their date of
birth and so we and as humans we can
generally work these things out we can
look at the records if we're looking at
list of people whose pensions we need to
pay out we will assume that they were
born and are over a hundred and so on
now go back in time a bit to when people
are writing computer software in the 60s
70s 80s
and 90's and memory at those time was at
a premium today we've got machines with
16 gigabytes of RAM even something like
the Raspberry Pi has up to 4 gigabytes
these days embedded on it but you go
back to the 60s when people started to
write software they only had a few
kilobytes and so one of the things they
wanted to do was try and use that memory
as wisely as possible now if you're
writing software in 1965 says just pick
a date when people are writing software
what people say is ok we don't need to
waste time writing 1919 1963 1939
whatever we could save memory by just
storing this as 1960 339 and so on so
they did when they wrote that a software
that was fine and they didn't expect
this software to still be running 40
years later probably still running 60
years later now and so on so this was a
fine optimization to make what people
realize is well actually we're coming up
to the point where we're gonna go from
1999 which would store as 99 to 2000
which we would store a 0-0 and then we'd
have 2001 which we stored a 1 and so on
now as we just saw for a human we've got
context about what the data is we can
make an educated guess so the
interesting thing though is that is
around this point here where we go from
storing things as 99 to 0 0 so up until
this point the numbers are all
increasing so 98 would have been less
than 99 which should have been less than
2000 but people didn't know how the
computers would react to suddenly going
from a number which they assumed would
be bigger and they wrote the software to
one that was significantly lower I mean
was this all in binary as well did it
matter was it were these I mean again
this was something else you had to take
into account software rewritten there's
a lot of different systems
you had binary coded decimal in use on
IBM mainframes and things you had
languages like COBOL in place that which
perhaps you wouldn't know how to program
people just didn't know at the time what
the situation was until you actually go
and do the Reese
you look at the software systems that
are in critical systems and you say well
okay is this going to cause a problem
and you need to work it out and if it is
you go and write a fix which is what
they did and if it isn't then you've got
a problem suppose that we're writing
software that assumes that we've got two
digits that represent the year so we'd
probably write code to print it out
maybe you see as an example there's
printf cents D / % d / 19 cent D and
then I printed a month yeah and if that
was just an integer variable then that
would print out 1999 fine but it would
print out in 2000 as 1 9 100 which you
would see instantly was a mistake but
suppose I've done the same sort of thing
and I've said ok I'm going to store just
two dates and I'm only gonna use 2 BCD
digits 2 story 2 binary coded decimal so
I've got 99 and I add 5 to that and that
gives me 0 4 and I then have some
software that says is this less than
this and that 9 plus 5 should be greater
than 99 but because we've wrapped around
it's no longer true and so you get
interesting issues happen there and the
problem was people just didn't know
which bits of software would happen what
would happen if those things were at
Brown I mean think about it if you've
got software controlling a nuclear
reactor that is using the sort of this
sort of format to store the date and you
say I want to test things every 10 days
and you say ok is current date greater
than date of next test and you've
wrapped around then you're going to be
continuously testing something because
the date is greater than what you
currently wrapped around - which may not
be a good thing to do to a nuclear
reactor I'll say those they don't have
any problems with nuclear reactors but
this is the sort of thing that you
needed to check and so people realize
this was a problem I think there's a
comment on it and using that in 1985 and
people actually said to the governments
look we need to look at this it could
potentially be a big problem perhaps you
wouldn't have had planes falling out the
sky but
as in the horror movies like to portray
it but it had the potential to cause
significant problems I mean probably
more likely you'd get problems at
people's pensions were no longer being
paid because it decided that they
haven't been born yet and things like
that we talk about it in terms of the
year 2000 burg the millennium bug but
actually you started to see these
problems earlier I mean someone who was
born in 1894 in 1994 would have been a
hundred but could also have been as we
saw there three months old and again you
would have started to see problems
showing there so there were signs that
this could be a problem and again people
started to take attempts to correct you
and those attempts could be simple as
saying well actually if it's a date
after the current date then we know but
then you get to the point where things
and you have to put assumptions and the
assumptions that we make as humans and
so on and of course it's not a problem
that was just limited to the year 2000
as lots of other instances where it it
has occurred or similar things might
occur in the future
I mean I've I introduced one myself I
remember texting a friend saying I've
just reintroduced the year 2000 bug and
as I was working on a BBC micro emulator
and I was throw some software that
counted the number of CPU cycles are
executed in a 32-bit integer and I was
surprised that my program kept crashing
after about 18 minutes until I worked
out if you've got two million cycles
every second after 18 minutes you would
have incremented that counter enough
times to overflow a signed 32-bit
integer so I then decided well the
easiest way to fix this was to confer
the value to a 64-bit integer because
that would allow the program to run for
several but several million years or
something another classic example was
wind early versions of Windows Windows
NT 4 would crash after 49.7 days because
they had a counter which counted the
number of milliseconds since the machine
was switched on and sort of it wrapped
around again you had similar problems
happening and things so it's a it's a
problem that's shown in multiple places
one that's potentially to come is in
UNIX UNIX tours time as the number of
seconds it's the first of January
nineteen
seventy and if as UNIX systems did
originally you use a 32-bit value to
store that number then on in 2038 that
number will wrap around back to the
beginning of 1970 again and so that
could cause problems now fortunately
people have seen this and most modern
versions of UNIX and Linux have moved
using 64 bits to represent the time
internally so it won't be a problem
again it'll be sufficiently far in the
future that I suspect we won't still be
running computer systems running UNIX
and if we are or we can convert it to
128-bit and recompile the software so
the millennium bug or things very
similar to that are seen in lots of
different places but it really did boil
down to those three things was how we
represent your data in the the programs
had been written to save memory by just
using two digits or to assume that it
was started from the beginning of the
1900s there was the fact that people
then made assumptions about how those
dates would work that a date wouldn't
always get bigger it'd be monotonically
increasing as we'd say and wouldn't
suddenly wrap around but then it did and
then there was the fact that software
often ends up running for a lot longer
than we expect and so perhaps when we're
writing software we ought to think about
the future problems and make sure we
sort of code around those assumptions or
at least document them and make say hang
on this will work until twenty thirty
eight or whatever it might be this row
moves too
so this goes to here this goes to here
this goes round back to here and so on
and this moves three right which is
another way of saying it moves that way
but it let you hit so this one goes
right back and pass the token on and
I've got it so I can load the value in
add the value from a register story back
and pass the token on